à l'occasion de la journée
internationale des personnes handicapées
la secrétaire d'état sophie cluzel s'est
rendu au château de versailles jeudi 3
décembre une visite qui a été l'occasion
de constater que ce monument vieux de
près de 400 ans s'adapte pour se rendre
accessible j'étais justement avec la
fondation de la française des jeux qui a
justement financer un ascenseur très
très bien fait cachez donc il ne détruit
pas justement c'est cet environnement
classés et pour autant il sert à tous
bien sûr aux personnes handicapées mais
aux familles nombreuses avec poussettes
donc on voit bien que quand on investit
sur l'accès à la différence on investit
pour tout le monde
bien sûr que c'est un défi mais c'est
possible nul doute inaccessible comme
lieu surtout des lieux de culture aussi
important que le château de versailles
en plus de la visite la secrétaire
d'état a tenu à faire un focus
particulier sur la politique d'emploi
des personnes handicapées au sein du
château normalement l'obligation d'en
passer 6 % ici on est à près de 10%
donc ça veut dire une vraie politique rh
inclusif sur près de 50 métiers et ce
qui est formidable c'est que dans un
château classé
eh bien on arrive à faire de
l'accessibilité pour tous les publics
donc on qu'on ne me dise plus ce n'est
pas possible s'ils contiennent volonté
quand une intelligence collective pour
rendre accessible et cheminon compliqué
eh bien on fait tout simplement l'accès
à la culture pour tous cette visite
ministérielle a aussi été l'occasion
pour le château de versailles de lancer
sa huitième édition de la semaine du
handicap
compte tenu du contexte sanitaire les
animations se feront pour la plupart à
distance toutefois des visites contées
adaptés sont aussi organisées